you don't do necessarily touring you do
shows yeah I do one off show sometimes
you'll just pop up and be like I have a
show today at 2m. man that's special
that's what special about this year
coming up because I'm doing um touring
in a non-traditional way I'm doing
residencies in different cities so
during the you know spring and winter we
going to be in venues and then when the
summer come I'm finding different
backyards in each of these cities where
we could do our thing still any uh any
La uh La is on the list LA is on the
list LA is on the list so when you're
going to do a residency in the city how
many shows in the year how many shows
per City let's say la what do we do four
five three yeah like six six okay y you
just need to find a spot yep I like that
this is the way people [__] I mean like
shout out to promoters but why would you
pay a promoter if you could promote
yourself just rent the venue cuz a lot
of [__] can't promote themselves and a
lot of [__] don't even promote their
own shows
this is true they they're really worried
about social media aesthetic right they
they don't want to look a certain way
hey bro that is the biggest pet peeve I
have with artists when they're so
worried about the aesthetic of how their
page looks that they won't even promote
their own [__] right that happens and it
just kind of tell it's like bro you
probably don't love what you
made like if you don't want to tell
people hey I made this [__] you probably
don't really enjoy what you made um
you've you have a great team um you guys
have come up with a system in terms
of the way you will repurpose content
yeah like if you go do an interview if
you go you know this will be repurposed
at time right hey you see your CLP for
the next six seven months um whether
it's a freestyle or you know you guys
shoot a backyard performance that ends
up you know living on on your IG on on
YouTube shorts whatever but you you guys
have a real uh onp purpose method of how
you schedule your post every day MH what
kind of post it is what time of day you
post break that down because I I think
if people saw the way you run your
content it's very inspiring and I think
you just don't have to be L like if
you're not lazy like there is like you
just got to keep on throwing shots into
the algorithm right like man we're just
curating a channel so I remember when we
first started um I had a bunch of live
sessions already because we used to do
the good company live session so I was
posting hell of those and then I started
doing interviews so I'm like all right
now we need to integrate interviews and
then we start doing shows and let's
let's integrate show footage and then
like now we'll have like real life
moments like I'm just hooping like the
other day I shot the ball from the roof
and it's like okay that's integrated
those four different types of content so
you can see me four times a day in a
different way so you're able to become a
fan in a different facet and you know
posting every few hours it's just like
if you have it and we toned it back like
we used to have so much and me and tia
sat and I was like all right now let's
let's let's hone it down let's only post
the pieces that we like man this this
made me feel good right and then we got
to that point it was like okay now let's
lock it down even more only post the one
that we look at each other at certain
point in time was it four or five times
a day yeah like six five six because I
do think like there's a couple of things
like like everyone have an excuse why
they don't have content to shoot um and
and I I don't I don't buy it anymore cuz
I got homies who are making six figures
in their life off of their phone off of
whatever app just chilling but you do
have you do have a team you have t who
helps you you have you have a team at
this point but it wasn't always like
that right but for you what is like the
Practical solution for an artist who has
2,000 monthly listeners who just is
putting out records trying to
follow you know I think a lot of artists
will see the path you take the path Russ
takes the path that a lot of artists
take in terms of throwing up shots
throwing up shots and they kind of feel
like they're it's just not working at a
certain point in time the music has to
be good right people have to buy into
you at a certain point in time and there
has to be that that' be my thing with
the industry when [__] be talking
about all the hit in the music cuz I'm
like you think I got to a million
followers organically if I don't have
you think these [__] come to my
backyard sold out time and sing every
lyric without the music they don't know
the lyrics to your artist song right we
don't know what the [__] he's
saying but I was going to say the
practicality of like that struggling up
and coming artist
who when they think of content it breaks
their brain and they think of like
because a lot of people you have to be
good at Instagram you have to be good at
like like for whatever reason like
people can respect it or not respect it
it's a talent to like really understand
how to cut up a a piece of content how
you
know for some there's so many different
routes you could take though I was
telling T the other day I love boozy and
Lil Duvall and like Charleston white cuz
they don't do content in a traditional
way it's just them being themselves
Gilly is one of those where he has
content but he's also a lot of his posts
is just him it's just him pulling his
phone out screaming about the Eagles in
front of a
TV if you don't have the ethic to figure
it out it's just not for you
just keep making excuses and complaining
it's just not for you if anybody who man
there's so many you can go shoot
visualizers we've had visualizers go
viral a visualizer is like a music video
but short form basically I write out a
whole music video treatment and I just
pick one scene and be like all right
let's shoot this and put the song on it
that [__] Cali Bon went viral a few
times outstanding doing numbers we'll do
those have you seen this guy anise yeah
y he's so good at I mean I've seen him
promote the same song for like over a
year in different ways he might be
sitting at a tennis court singing a song
he might be on a bro if you take one
song and you do a live Rec a live
performance one with your instrumental
one with a guitarist one with a Pianist
you got three different pieces of
content and one might go then you can
start doing specialty [__] go outside
and record your [__] do it live like
it's just so many things you could do
for a [__] to be like I don't know what
to do it's like you're not trying you're
not trying and you're
scared that it's not going to work that
too right people are scared well what
happens if I throw something up and it
makes me look crazy CU cuz social media
is transparency so if you throw
something up and it don't do well people
will see and your insecurities your
insecurities will prevent you from from
getting over that hump you got to do it
failure is data yeah you're not going to
make every single shot you take mhm and
I always tell people too you can upload
new re like you could re-upload reels
but not have it on your feed just throw
it back into the system right so it pops
up um so music-wise I we know what
you're doing in the New Year how I mean
you're always working on new albums
they're coming out all the time what's
what's what's uh what's coming next man
we got a project with link up coming I'm
going to drop before the year close
that'll be album Number 30 and then I
just did uh some incredible songs with
this producer named Mike G okay um from
Chicago that [__] coming
I got [__] with do I'm always making
music like that that's my passion I love
to make music so I don't think I'm ever
not going to be
dropping would you ever sell your
catalog like people are selling their
catalogs I wouldn't it's a thing you
know people are getting bags yeah no
people do um I personally wouldn't would
you ever sell a piece of it for the
right price n i license it though but I
wouldn't I
wouldn't like say somebody to just build
new homes with people like and that's
been something I've been running into
with like trying to do deals with label
or dros cuz they all want your catalog
and I'm like no I spent years building
my own [__] and marketing putting my own
money you're not getting my catalog but
I will build new homes with you we could
do 25 30 50 new things but you're not
going to get all the work doing for the
last four years yeah yeah yeah that's
real